hello everyone i'm alana and welcome to
my channel and i am
going home
i'm so excited i could cry but there's a
bunch of reasons that i need to actually
tell you about this other than just me
being very excited though i do like
making a youtube video that is just
about excitement
positivity man there's a lot of angry
people on this website but i actually
before we get to the details of me going
home and what it means for content
because
i'm going home for a while and i have to
be locked in a hotel room for two weeks
with a guard i don't even know
the hotel room yet they don't actually
tell you where you're going until you
get to australia they like pick you up
take you to a hotel
leave you in there for two weeks it's a
whole thing but
before we get to that i have something
i'm very very excited to reveal today so
some of you have asked me before um
about making more merch and i've always
said i'm okay with doing merch for
charity but generally i'm kind of
uncomfortable with it and i did say when
i said that
with one exception of this very cool
thing
that i get to show you guys today i
think it's so
cool this is a youtubes
you've probably heard about them
basically i helped design this figure
i think it's so cool that is of me
let's actually take it out of the box
shall we do a little mini unboxing
inside of this update video
so the box itself is also like you know
we designed it
to look it's so neat clearly
unintentionally fits the entire
aesthetic of my background in this video
they got me on brand pretty well here
so we open it up boom it's me
i gave them some like specific insights
so these shoes are obviously
supposed to look like my uh most
expensive
pair of jordans we got pants we got the
regular old
black hoodie that i'm virtually always
wearing got the silver hair
with the brown eyebrows this is a coffee
cup and this is a controller
which is like i love it i think we did a
really good job so yeah what i'm telling
you about today is basically that uh
this is limited edition once it's sold
out it will never be made again and we
have a giveaway that you guys can enter
to win if we go over here it is
alanapierce.youtube.com
link is also in the description you can
go straight here and basically
follow youtube's on twitter youtube and
reddit for entries so if we go here
visit youtube's on youtube and go
subscribe there we go
and then you just add in your contact
details and they will reach out to you
if you have one but outside of the
giveaway
the thing is actually coming out on may
21st at 12 p.m pacific time limited
edition that's it
i think it's so neat um so yeah if you
want to get one
feel free but back to the topic of this
video
um basically i'm here to tell you guys
that i'm going home and i am extremely
excited so for anyone who doesn't know i
live in los angeles i've lived in
california for six years now and i've
not been able to go home for the past
year and a half so it's been
a year and a half since i've seen a
single family member it's actually
technically been the last time i did was
in 2019
so we're in 2021 now it has been
much too long and it was very hard for
me during the pandemic to be so far from
home and be dealing with this you know
an entirely different continent on a
different time zone
with no hope of seeing my family now i
am fully vaccinated i am two weeks after
my second shot
um i'm more comfortable flying because
of course i am high risk so that was
definitely a concern
but it's also been very hard to get into
australia the reason i'm going home is
because my sister is pregnant
um which is extremely exciting this is
the first time she has been pregnant i
am going to be an
aunt i have like a couple of things i
want to talk about it because i know my
sister watches my youtube videos so
we're not going to talk about the things
pretend you didn't hear that sarah you
should blank it out it didn't happen you
didn't hear i didn't say anything about
any things
okay but i'm really excited so
basically what that means is that about
halfway through may
i get on a plane and then i have to go
to
a hotel room like i said that i um well
i guess first step is you land
they get you on a bus they take you
straight to a hotel
but you can't leave the hotel for two
weeks that's how australian quarantine
works and i guess
why the country has done so well in the
face of covered
is they are very strict about quarantine
so i'll be stuck in a hotel for two
weeks
so first up i mean i have to give the
biggest thanks of all time
to my job um for being so supportive
about this like every single person i've
spoken to was like of course family's so
important
um so i will be working on u.s time
still working while i'm there but i
really i've worked for companies who
really aren't supportive about this
stuff they have been so wonderful to the
extent that i just keep needing to tell
everybody like tell my manager and be
like this is
this is so nice that everyone's like hey
we're really excited for you this is
awesome
uh and obviously writing is easy to do
remote really but i'm not gonna get into
too many of those details i just wanted
to add that publicly because it's been
so freaking wonderful
how um how cooperative we've been able
to be about this and
them letting me do it is amazing but
yeah the first two weeks i don't know
what my internet connection's gonna be
like
um because i don't know where i'm going
to be staying for two weeks
you don't even get to like pick your own
food they just kind of bring you
whatever they want
it's a lot i'm very glad that the mass
effect trilogy comes out
very close to me flying because that's
what i intend to do for all the downtime
that i'm just in that hotel room and
unable to leave
even though i'm vaccinated but yeah i
don't know what my internet connection
is gonna be like obviously i will be
prioritizing work if there's any kind of
cap or
whatever else um so that potentially
means we won't be able to do the podcast
it potentially means no streams during
that period of time it potentially means
i'll probably still be able to make
youtube videos because what else am i
going to be doing in a hotel room but
you know my uploads
could take the whole night i don't know
so
while i'm in the hotel room don't know
what content output is going to be like
that extends to when i'm out of the
hotel room as well if i'm being
honest i think doing the podcast uh play
watch listen will be completely fine
um i will just probably have to have
somebody else record and maybe my
connection will suck but you know there
that i think will be will be okay um
should still be
weekly i'm just gonna have to be
recording it at like 1am or 2am
it's gonna be wild but that should be
fine i really don't know if
any of my family members have fast
enough internet for me to be able to
stream though
so i still intend to make youtube videos
in the exact same way that i
already would while i'm at home for
however long it ends up being
which i'm being intentionally vague
about because some people have had
issues leaving australia when they go
home if they're citizens
some of them can't get out um i think i
will be okay but there is a chance that
you know dates will shift around or
whatever
so yeah i really don't know we're gonna
find out
together in real time i do think like i
said
youtube channel stuff should be pretty
much the same maybe a little bit less
frequent in upload so i can spend time
with my family so i can be there for my
sister giving birth and
help with anything that my family needs
during that period of time
um which is just so so so so exciting
but
i still intend to upload at least two
three videos a week i don't think that
will be
difficult for me to do especially
because it times out during e3 so it'll
probably be like watching the e3 press
conferences or reacting to those or
you know talking about some of the e3
news um makes it very easy to know
what's coming out at that point in time
so i think i think that'll all be okay
but yeah for twitch streams for that
period of time i really don't know so
anyone who's following me on twitch
it's entirely possible that that whole
period of time i won't be able to stream
um because
australian internet in a lot of cases in
a lot of places is as bad as they say
folks
it's terrible but otherwise i would
generally intend to do it
you know probably pretty much on
american hours because i am going to be
working american hours to make sure that
i can still communicate with my team at
work so i feel like i hope i can do it
because the rest of my family is just
going to be asleep
most of the time that i'm awake uh
outside of like some of the days off
that i will be taking to spend time with
family so yeah i basically just wanted
to give everyone a heads up and an
update before i actually go
that i don't know what content is going
to look like for this period of time
um it'll be very up in the air podcast
might disappear streams might disappear
i truly have no clue which
is very difficult uh and frustrating
to prepare for but you know
i get to go home i can't wait to see my
family honestly i love my family so much
it is the hardest thing about living in
the us is being away
from my family who i absolutely adore
and i think about it every single day
they are so important to me and uh i'm
very very very excited i really think i
need it i think it's gonna be hard to
leave if i'm being honest it's going to
be hard to come back to the us
especially because australia
has like really done well with the
pandemic that things are open
it'll be like going back to the real
world and then having to come back to la
where some things are still shut down
and so yeah just a quick update video
wanted to share the youtube
thing wanted to let people know
basically the situation for while i'm at
home
which actually let me check what day i'm
publishing this yeah by the time that
i'm publishing this i will already be in
australia actually
so it's starting now ladies and
gentlemen
starting right now who knows what's
happening i guess we'll find out but
that is it for me today everyone
hopefully
future ilana in her hotel room prison is
doing okay so far
all right i will see you all next time